why václav Matt Cox is an unlikely
ladies man
he's diminutive to me the mean so look
so the guy that we stole the house rumor
we got the house from here's a quote
from him in the book is at the beginning
of each chapter I but here's a quote I
put and his name was a Steven Jackson
real estate investor he put it's almost
impossible to stop them when they're
this talented and smart as smart as
these people Wow
so I have a bunch of quotes from just
different things that people have said
throughout the whole thing but I
remember I had a quote from him it's a
good quote but what he lacks in height
he makes up for in street smarts he was
very persuasive as far as how he handled
things looked at our apartment got
things I needed the party and he was in
charge of a lot okay so I'd liked that I
liked that he could you know the way he
handled things
[Music]
Matt Cox grew up in Tampa he showed an
early whoa look at that how old were you
there 17 Jesus studied art in college
in an exclusive phone interview with
American greed Cox says he always knew
art was no way to get rich quick I mean
I never expected to be an artist because
I was gonna be good not for making
enough money as an artist to survive his
real talent is the art of the kind and
the knack for finding the perfect
sidekick they were a single mother hero
divorced they had money problems they
met him by and large and on online
dating services where he came across as
this sort of smart well-to-do mortgage
broker you know whose artistic and who
is this guy this is Jeff testerman he
wrote 3435 articles on me over the st.
Petersburg Times he's kind of like the
guy that broke the story
oh really yeah really has a great sense
of humor and drives a nice car I think
that the women while vulnerable wanted a
piece of the pie as well he could tell
that I was you know someone that
wouldn't tell on him and you know he
could but in the meantime he's offering
me all this money and saying he wants to
take care of my son and ice and Brice to
a private school and I'm thinking you
know okay I knew about him on finally
you know I can I met someone that I know
everybody wants to take care of my son I
am doing it and not really paying
attention to the or not wanting me to
pay attention to what he was doing I
want your online in order
we've been on that Cox decides Rebecca
Howe doesn't day I doubt most he shows
her a good time
charms and takes her to a movie that
could be about his own life
we saw matchstick man and it's about a
con we did see that time man a con
artist
I think it is about the flim-flam man
matchstick man loser whatever you want
to call it ticket a lot of it was
probably me just wanting to overlook it
more so than being realistic and
thinking okay what are you getting
involved in here when American greed
returns Matt Cox and Rebecca Hawke go on
the run and swindle the world's biggest
bank what bank was it the world's
biggest bank you said the Bank of
America oh no this is great so far
con artists you prefer con artists /
conman artists and it's true in Kappa a
rogue mortgage broker named Matt Cox is
assuming fake identities to take out
multiple mortgage loans on properties he
doesn't own pocketing the money and
making millions in the process
the year is 2003 in a red hot real
estate market the conman hides in plain
sight everybody was getting rich
everybody was flipping property jeff
testerman is an investigative reporter
with the st. Petersburg Times in the
fall of 2003 he gets a tip from an
associate of Matt Cox and we began to
fall and he suggested things to me the
way a good source is supposed to do he
gave me the leads and I went to court
house and got the documentary evidence
to show that he was telling the truth
testerman source says that Matt Cox the
artist is using a palette of fake names
I called them color coded aliases
Charles Hoyt
James red Brandon green Matt Cox had a
sense of humor about these things
Cox uses the aliases to create Shaq
Reservoir Dogs Reservoir Dogs
I have William blue I had Lee black I
had mr. Michael White I had Brandon
green James red David silver but a bunch
of them a bunch of them that's where you
got it from yeah yeah that's great yeah
the guys were the guy had the way I was
doing because that the people don't
exist so who's going into the clothing
right right so I the title companies
would let with because I was had because
of the mortgage company and we were
doing so many mortgages you could go to
a title company if you were the broker
and you could say look my guys at work
can I bring him the title stuff to the
title policy or sorry can I bring the
closing documents to his work and let
him sign them and they're like I'm
supposed to be there to notarize it and
they you know but you know if you're
closing a bunch of loans with this this
title company what are they gonna say
it's like you know hey man what's the
big deal we closed [ __ ] ten loans
here last month 20 what you know and
they're like all right all right
they give me give it to me so they give
me the package and I'd have Lea black
sign the documents I go sit in the
parking lot inside the
[ __ ] documents and then I say make
sure you get a copy of the driver's
license no problem
I get I to have a copy of the driver's
license I put it down I'd go back in and
I'd hand it to him they go thanks Matt
and then they'd notarize their signature
the guy was never there they'd hand me
all the checks and I'd leave I've got
all the checks they've got a closing
package the lender has a closing package
I make three or four payments five six
payments and then I let it the let the
place go into foreclosure
so what wouldn't have happening one time
so I never went to a close I only end up
going to one closing at SunTrust I
borrowed $250,000 and I went in as James
read but I think was James right anyway
one time we were doing closings and
someone somehow or another the title
agent figured out she figured out that
something wasn't right like somebody
told her I'm almost positive someone did
tell her somebody told her look these
loans that you're closing these people
don't exist because suddenly she called
the mortgage broker and she said listen
this guy James read the next closing he
has he has to show up well when I made
these fake driver's licenses I would I
would I need a photo so I would go
online to Hillsborough County's arrest
records and I would just get a photo
well for James red I was using the photo
of a guy named Eric tamargo a guy that
used to trim lots for us like he'd
trimmed the trees and clean the yards
everything and haul away garbage or was
life I bought a piece-of-shit house for
40 grand he'd clean up the yard and take
the stuff away so I I had gone online
one day and I found his picture I was
like [ __ ] so I used his picture for
James read put it in there not thinking
anything you know it's just more of a
joke yeah cuz a lot of the guys were
people I I knew because I thought you
know maybe if I need the guy I need to
know the guy I don't know just felt like
a pickle yeah I could at least go to him
and maybe try and get him to act as a
person some I wasn't sure so anyway what
happens is this chick Mary at the time
company calls up and tell it says look
James red has to show up at the next
closing she knows something's wrong so
fine so the broker calls me and tells me
that and I'm like um okay well he's got
to show up then and she was well how is
he gonna show up he's a mug shot on the
Hillsborough County web site and I was
like I'm gonna [ __ ] go Domenic god I
gotta track the guy down I'm gonna get
I'll get him to show up and she goes
[ __ ] so I call up Eric and Eric comes in
I say hey Eric what's up and he uses
that he was a man what's going on I said
look I need to tell you something you
know all these houses but we've been
flipping we've been buying and you think
yeah yeah yeah I know said okay let me
tell you what we're doing what's really
happening and I explained it to him
behind the houses for 40 we're recording
them at 200 we're borrowing 160 we're
[ __ ] walking away with a chunk of
cash we're reinvesting the money that's
what we're doing fake people he's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] man that's [ __ ] him that
salt Mouse bro that's Besame wasn't
pissed he didn't know yet oh I was using
his picture and I was like anger right
um so he sat there's a man here so why
are you telling me bro I said well
because this woman found out something's
wrong and she's saying that this guy
James red has to show up his [ __ ] bro
he's who you're gonna get to show up I
go I was thinking you and he goes oh
[ __ ] bro that's a that's a big favor
that's a big favor and I go I mean it's
a big favor Eric I said he is man oh no
and I said and he goes well wait a
minute I can't show up anyway bro he is
you're using you said you're using some
scumbags [ __ ] picture off the off the
[ __ ] Hillsborough County website I
went that is true I said the problem is
Eric I said I've been using your picture
from when you beat up your wife a couple
of years ago remember you find a slapped
her around I said I you got arrested I
said I used you he's [ __ ] he jumps
up and he's ready to [ __ ] swing this
dude would beat the brakes off me by the
way it's not the [ __ ] guy to [ __ ]
with
he's like a street tough guy and I'm
like well I'm like hey the only reason I
used your picture the only reason I use
a picture is because I knew if it came
to this you were the only person I knew
that would have the balls to pull this
off I'm asked [ __ ] it's a silver tongue
oh yeah he looked at me goes
yeah shrew bro that's true okay looks
like he goes why I'm doing it for free
hey I'm not doing it for free I said no
no of course not bro mean obviously I'll
pay ya so what do you want and he goes I
don't remember thinking if he asked for
like more than like 10 15 grand I'll
[ __ ] change title companies and I'll
go in myself like I didn't want to go in
myself I'm already on federal probation
hmm so I was like I'll just go with my
[ __ ] self I'll redo the ID I'll do
this I and he sat there and I said what
do you want man what do you want I'm
thinking if he asked for more than ten
or fifteen and he goes I want $500 and I
went say no more
$500 Jesus God Almighty are you serious
500 bucks it's five minutes it's gonna
be fun
so I are she with him like it's a big
dick he's like no man are you doing for
us to Ri Ri Ri era all right but I'm not
giving you the money till you sign no of
course I'll saw him first sure no
problem I know you're good for it great
we go in we go into the [ __ ] title
company III make him a fake ID he walks
in Mary comes out and walks in the day
of the closing she walks out and sees me
sitting there she has mr. Cox why are
you here I said I'm not doing the
closing les James red shows up so Eric
stands up and goes I'm James red and she
goes hold on one second she goes gets
the file comes back pulls out the
[ __ ] picture that I've been using of
their drivers license holds it up and
goes you could see in her face like [ __ ]
like what I don't know what's going on
now now she thought she knew now she
don't know now she's like someone said
this and it didn't make sense and this
[ __ ] guy it's she's I'm sorry mr. red
oh come on in so he says do you have
your driver's license yeah I don't have
my ID on my driver's license because I
didn't want to make I couldn't get the
same picture so I I matched it up and
she's like [ __ ] he closes when we get to
closing he seems like ten thousand goes
to Dave Walker fifteen thousand goes to
this guy three thousand goes here seven
thousand Chax he's starting to put it
together this is a lot of money
is $100,000 is being shifted around I'm
getting 500 bucks so we get out and I
counter I can't give him his 500 bucks
and he goes yo bro he's like there was a
lot of [ __ ] money and it's a lot of
money he said I mean I'm doing it for
500 I said I said a lot of that money
goes back in the house Eric and he's
like well who's a big deal so he leaves
like a week later I call him back I need
you to do another one he's like [ __ ] he
was alright bro he's I'll tell you right
now I ain't doing it for no 500 bucks I
saw them checks I know you guys are
making [ __ ] Bank
I went okay bro but what is it what do
you want he goes it's a big favor
getting a lot of trouble I said I know
you could bro I know you could what do
you want
he's I won $1,000 I'm sorry are you
serious Eric a thousand Jesus man that's
twice what you Charlie man I get a lot
of trouble I said all right bro all
right but you got a sign for naw naw
I'll sign for we go in again boom he
signs Mary was so [ __ ] bamboozled the
next time that I actually call up and
schedule a closing I say hey Mary can I
pick up the [ __ ] thing this time or
you still got to see this guy no no it's
okay and she lets me take the package
Jesus starts all over and so that's how
like that's the only time I had to have
one so they show up then I ended up
showing up like one of the last loans
that closes close for 250 I just showed
up myself because it was everything was
just so streamlined it was working so
well right let's seem that we're working
so well yeah until the Alison thing
happened and then it all just kind of
[ __ ] I didn't know it was I rather
like hero
[Music]
[Laughter]